When a long-running TV series comes to an
end, fans can sometimes get a little bit emotional.
But plenty of Game of Thrones enthusiasts
aren't just sad about the show ending - they're
mostly feeling angry about how it all wrapped
up.
That unrest has given rise to a petition demanding
HBO remake the eighth and final season with
a whole new team of writers, a tall order
that they hope at least sends a clear message
to the people in charge of the show.
"There's a fierceness you don't often see.
They'd do anything to protect their babies."
The online petition gained international attention
as the final episode of the series drew near.
By the day after the divisive finale, it had
already received well over a million signatures.
One person who was unaware of the petition's
existence was the actress whose unexpected
character turn arguably started the intense
fan outcry in the first place.
Daenerys Targaryen actress Emilia Clarke was
told about the petition when she sat down
for an interview with the New Yorker, during
which she gamely offered her ideas for a hypothetical
"do-over."
But Clarke also said, she's, quote, "in no
position to critique the geniuses that have
written eight seasons’ worth of wonderful
stuff."
"Not a true story, necessarily."
Clarke revealed that she would have loved
if Daenerys interacted with her handmaiden,
Missandei, and her greatest enemy, Cersei
Lannister, more than she did during Season
8.
She also said she wanted to, quote, "see a
bit more" discussion between characters during
the controversial fifth episode of the season,
which followed Daenerys and her allied forces
as they stormed King's Landing.
When the city surrendered in a peaceful manner
during the climactic episode, the Mother of
Dragons suddenly made a heel turn toward sheer
madness, ordering her dragon to burn down
everything in sight.
Clarke has since said that Dany's tumbling
into madness was inevitable, but she would
have enjoyed additional conversations being
included in between all the action.
She explained to the New Yorker,
"The genocide was there.
That was always going to happen.
And I just think [...] that we are more than
happy to contently sit there and watch ten
minutes of two people talking, because it's
beautiful.
I just wanted to see a bit more of that."
Clarke also expressed a desire, in her idea
of a hypothetical do-over, to see Dany's,
quote, "last images being that of kind of
a hopeful, childlike love" before she dies
in the arms of her lover-slash-nephew, Jon
Snow, who tragically slays her out of a certainty
that she'll cause more harm than good to the
people of Westeros.
Clarke said Daenerys' death was a, quote,
"shocker to read," but the actress also admitted
that she isn't sure the character could have
had a more triumphant ending.
As she put it,
"I always knew that the show was never going
to satisfy everyone.
[...] The stories are too vast, the characters
too complex.
The show is, in a certain way, divisive: 'Whose
side are you on?'
Also, if you're pleasing everyone, then it's
probably quite tepid.
But to me it seemed like the only way it could
end."
It couldn't have been easy for Clarke to come
to terms with what happened to her character,
whom she has played since 2011, on the final
two episodes of Game of Thrones.
Her response to the petition asking for a
re-do is incredibly level-headed - which is
admirable considering Clarke's Daenerys was
the only major character to die in the final
episode.
It's unlikely that those who hated Game of
Thrones' final season will suddenly change
their minds after hearing Clarke's response
to the online backlash, but perhaps her diplomatic
disposition might inspire them to ease up
a little.
If the woman who had to play the character
who went mad, killed thousands, and got stabbed
to death over the course of two episodes can
remain calm about the situation, the people
who only had to witness the calamity should
be able to do the same.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.